لكن السحره بيضا قد ينقلب ضده توجيه
البوصله الى الداخل سيضعه تحت المجهر وهذا
تحديدا يخدم خطه الجمهوريين فتحت هذه
القبه وبعد حسم نتيجه مجلس النواب بدا
الحزب الجمهوري بتسديد اولى ضرباته لراس
الهرم الديمقراطي
ملف الفساد يلاحق نجل الرئيس الابن وهي
الوسيله والاب هو الغايه بدانا من ملاحقتي
مساله اخرى يتطلع الجمهوريون لوضع حد لها
وتعارض قطط الرئيس وحزبه سياسه الشيك على
بياض السخيه بالنسبه للمساعدات الاوكرانيه
وعلى الارجح انها ستتوقف معركه الحدود
الاولى من معركه اوكرانيا الحسبه جمهوريه
طبعا المتوقع كذلك ان يقضي ان يقضي
الاعضاء الجمهوريون ساعات طويله بكتابه
تشريعات مناهضه للصين الحرب الصين
التجاريه طبعا بالدرجه الاولى بعكس
الديمقراطيين بدفع الجمهوريين لتعزيز
ضوابط التصدير اولا للحد من تسرب
التكنولوجيا وثانيا لحمايه حقوق الملكيه
الفكريه وبالنتيجه ستطلب المواجهه مع
الصين خفضه سقف المعايير البيئي زياده
امريكا الاقتصاديه خط احمر لكن كل هذا
سياتي على حسابي ملف المناخ ويدفعوا بصدام
كبير مع الحزب الديمقراطي وهذا يقودنا
للحديث عن ازمه الطاقه مخزون امريكا من
الديزل المحدد واسعار الوقود مضطربه جدا
والى ارتفاع وحل المشكله سيكون بتامين
طاقه من مصادر لا يفضلها الديمقراطيون
وتاتي على حساب قضيه الاحتباس الحراري اذا
ملفات اخرى ستفتح جبهات الحرب في اروقه
الكونجرس والحرب ستتحول الى كرنبالا ساخن
ومصير اعظم دوله لن يكون في احسن
اهي اذا تباعدت الرؤى وضاقت مساحه الخلاف
البناء بين الحزبين
[موسيقى]